hi i am carla gugino hi i'm lena heary
hello i'm karen gillan and we are the
cast of gunpowder milkshake and we are
here with buzzfeed
to play a game of who's who
[Music]
so who's the most likely to start
laughing and break character
during a take karen gillan how dare you
i was gonna say everyone is highly
professional so
i'm not sure i'm gonna say oh i probably
is myself you're right you're right
i've turned into a real corpser
shockingly unprofessional
it was funny though who's most likely to
get caught
taking a nap between scenes it's me
isn't it
yes it's you well hold my hands up to
this because
literally i had them give me a bed
instead of a chair like you know those
chairs that you see actors sitting
around set on i got a bed and then lena
copied me and got a bed didn't you
definitely karen because also you were
working the hardest you're working the
longest hours you had
so many freaking stunts that's the
reason yeah and yeah you had a cot
and you got to use it you needed to
recoup your bones
good that's why i was napping it's not
that i'm lazy
never who is most like their gunpowder
milkshake
character parlor because i've never
met anyone so immediately makes you feel
so comfortable ever i agree i echo that
sentiment you're also really well read
and play a librarian my day is going up
from here ladies coming for me
i was gonna say chloe maybe because she
just was looking at us the whole time
like we're the crazy people and she's
just like
staying you know staying on point who is
at least
like their gunpowder milkshake character
you lina you
are at least like your gunpowder
wheelchair character because
you're the best mom ever in real life
you messed up in the movie as a mother
but in real life very
very excellent you always are putting
your kids first and that is
actually an amazing and very difficult
thing to do in this business so
thanks ladies tequila coming your way
[Laughter]
okay who's most likely to nail a stunt
on the first
take and i gotta go to michelle yeah oh
yeah of course the action hero i was
gonna go michelle or lina because i saw
lena like flying through the air on
wires firing guns and screaming and i
thought i can't do that that scares me
but it's
fine but michelle yeah too because she's
obviously like action royalty
and did you also notice that michelle is
always eating these like amazing
concoctions
that i feel we should all know about
there's like a broth with collagen in it
and she's the tiniest person but she's
so agile and she makes every action
sequence look like a ballet and then she
also was like firing a machine gun at
one point and didn't even blink
i had loots the weapon like you have to
open your eyes
when i was playing a us marshall once
and i had to shoot a lot i would you
know blink and everything and i was like
yeah
how do you not do this and he said every
cop does it too it's only
in film that they want you to keep your
eyes open who's most likely to pull a
prank on set
we chloe oh my god she was getting me
all the time especially towards the end
of the shoot
she'll be like there's rats in here and
her acting is so believable
that i was like i thought there was rats
and i was getting like really nervous
i feel like you answered that question
really well who's most
likely to randomly burst into song
who pointing at you i don't know what
you're talking about
definitely karen and it also makes me
feel like
maybe we need to do a musical imagine
like a fight sequence that's so
vicious and brutal but you're singing
through it i mean it would be good it
would be good cardiovascular and
good for the lungs too excellent yeah
good diaphragm like get that
core i think you just burst a new genre
action musical
i actually don't think karen there was
one take where you didn't sing
i know i don't realize i'm even doing it
anymore like i don't know what that is
and it must be so annoying and i'm sorry
finally the apology we've been waiting
for who's most likely to send a funny
meme or video to a group chat with the
cast
lina i i feel like you led the charge of
some very good behind-the-scenes
material in a very small amount of time
it flowed organically from you yeah i
vote
you're the queen of the videos i think
we all possess
many many talents that needed to be uh
exposed
i don't feel like we had enough enough
of them frankly though i feel like we
just
it's the tip of the iceberg ladies we
just gave you the tip everyone
who would you definitely trust with a
secret
i vote carla i vote carla wow guys i am
a vault i will tell you that
anything you tell me in confidence will
never part these lips wanna tell me a
secret right now i think it's a great
time to do it
i feel like we're just really intimate
right now and finally
who's the best at doing an impression of
another cast member
definitely not me that's for sure i'm a
terrible impressionist
i think i can do karen but not very well
go on i'll do leena
do nothing what's a lena thing to say
i don't know
going to go over here
[Laughter]
should i do that again again
i thought you were asking if you should
do your impression again to which the
answer is yes
thank you for tuning in to this genius
bet you're glad you did
a milkshake is coming out and you should
watch it because it's good it's fun and
it's coming out july 14th on netflix usa
in cinemas internationally whoa what she
said
exactly